here's a really subtle key to
collaborations the best collaboration is
when you and I have 50/50 intent really
the best collaboration is actually a
little bit more nuanced it's that you
and I had 50/50 intent but we both
understand that it may turn out being
7327 there's too many nuances that go
into it I've done tons of collaborations
where they have not worked out for me
but I felt good about it because I knew
the other person
try I day trade attention and build
businesses Legacy is greater than
current
I'm a pure bread entrepreneur for real
for real for real like
documented serial entrepreneur Gary
vaynerchuk founder of vriends has
partnered with Gregory's coffee to
create the Jolly Jacko it's a pumpkin
chai latte that's based on the V Friends
character what are you and Gregory doing
so I created this world be friends
there's about 250 different characters
think of it for everyone at home as a
Pokemon meet Sesame Street these really
cool characters that are collectible and
competitive but pushing good virtues
when Vayner media just got going on 23rd
in park Gregory's was the choice of all
of our employees we reached out and said
hey would you want to do something where
we could put this character into a
unique new beverage they were gracious
enough to team up and now people are
running all over the city going to
Gregory's to pick them up so when Gary
came to you and said he wanted to do
this collaboration what' you think
immediately connected with Gary I knew
he stands for a lot of the similar
things we to preaching positivity hard
work entrepreneurship all the things
that obviously are Testament to me and
how we've grown this company so I
thought it was perfect I think the thing
that kind of makes it all work for me is
I don't struggle if something isn't
going well for a short period of time I
wonder if this is why you've been
successful I like doing so many
different things and I'm not trying to
actually maximize wealth even though I
talk about like I'd love to buy the Jets
and it's fun to Chase them I do all
these things not because I think it's
going to maximize my money it's because
I like it I I need a lot of different
[Music]
things we're in this incredible setting
here in Midtown Manhattan with a fellow
entrepreneur from the East Coast I
admire very much Gregory's coffee we're
really excited about the Jolly Jacko
pumpkin spice chai latte collab that
we're doing basically every collab I do
I make pretend I'm fully the other
person and what would I say yes to I
need them to feel like that was the best
decision they made what I liked about
this one of my requests is like hey I
really wanted to be a new drink like
just slapping my my Jolly Jacko on
exactly it doesn't feel authentic in
reverse the word collab collaboration
please go Google it because what I see
from a lot of you when you try to do a
collaboration is you try to win the deal
it's what about me yeah Bayer Nation
thank you please get your ass to New
York New Jersey connector DC find a
Gregor's and Order loudly and proudly a
jolly Jacko pumpkin spice chai latte
thanks for listening thank you the the
definition of collaboration is to work
together why do you think we have such a
hard
time a lot of people come from a mindset
of scarcity and you don't have to win
the deal you win the deal when both
people feel great about it people
struggle with trying to find the balance
between being good for them and being
good for yourself and I think that's
just all relationships here's a really
subtle key to collaborations the best
collaboration is when you and I have
50/50 int
really the best collaboration is
actually a little bit more nuanced it's
that you and I had 50/50 intent but we
both understand that it may turn out
being 7327 there's too many nuances that
go into it I've done tons of
collaborations where they have not
worked out for me but I felt good about
it because I knew the other person
[Music]
tried take that
that's how you do it okay welcome to
October's wine of the month club I am
here Gary Vayner former host of Wine
Library TV Brandon three epic red wines
as we are now in red wine season we're
in the fall though it is nice in the
[Music]
year what what I most enjoy about things
like this is the Serendipity of a night
like this when I kind of look around and
realize how many people are going to
connect for the first time and what
that's actually going to lead to one of
the things that all of you are doing as
you continue to produce content and put
it out there is You're Building
reputation many of you in this room know
that I pounded and yelled and screamed
every single day saying tick tock tick
tock tick tock Tik Tok when everybody
was scared to leave Instagram cuz that's
where they had their audience most of
the unlock of growth and being genuinely
happier is predicated on all the things
a lot of you want to say but you don't
post about because you're posting for
growth not posting for
purpose I just want to tell you
something because I feel like I wouldn't
be right here right now without you
because two years ago I applied to work
for your company I went through three
rounds of interviews and then I got
rejected the one critique I was like I
think one or two rounds away from
talking with you directly but um the one
critique they said was that I needed to
be posting more for myself on my social
media and then you went and did
it I'm so proud of you if it wasn't for
that I would not be here I'm so proud of
you good for
you all right everybody I'm in my office
I'm about to go live in our Fanatics
live studio we're about to give away a
ton of so I'm super excited about
[Music]
that what's good fanatic slide what's
good woo
the following item is for auction it is
a perfect Persian cat 9 rare but the
kicker is you also get 15 minutes with
me oneon-one next week on Google
Hangout we're doing a huge
giveaway right now get ready we're doing
an auction right now one of the biggest
right off my wall one1 physical
canvas
we love you we got a lot coming up hope
you had a lot of fun wish you well give
me your feedback love you bye appreciate
everyone support yeah let's clap it
up it was a wild day the life of
an entrepreneur operator who sees
happiness and joy as part of the
equation I think so much more happiness
and fun needs to be a part of all your
entrepreneurial Journeys so I hope you
enjoyed all the stuff we did a lot of
different looks today a lot of V friends
Bay Rex we'll give it to you all love
you and see you
[Music]
yeah